Featuring multiple cancellations, a surprising
reveal, and lots of propane and propane accessories,
Hank, Peggy, and Bobby's journey to the "King
of the Hill" finale has been long and eventful.
"King of the Hill" holds up due in no small
part to its forgiving attitude toward the
peculiarities of its characters.
The show makes no bones about their shortcomings,
but it always gives them space to grow.
Many of the characters are based on personalities
from series creator Mike Judge's childhood,
giving the whole show a sense of down-to-earth
realism that was rare in comedies of its time.
Jokes that would have quickly descended into
cheap shots in most other sitcoms have a way
of disarming themselves instead over the course
of episodes.
The series almost always leads with a message
of acceptance, though its also never afraid
to poke fun at the over-the-top traits of
its ensemble.
"Why do you have to hate what you don't understand?"
"I don't hate you, Bobby!"
Hank Hill's family and friends feel like people
you might meet at the grocery store or at
a company picnic.
The relationship between Peggy and Hank is
impressively committed and supportive, and
any apprehension they feel about Bobby's outlandish
interests and decisions is eventually outweighed
by their desire to let him express himself.
Despite occasional slow episodes or jokes
that don't land, the cleverness of "King of
the Hill" often lies in its refusal to pretend
to be anything but what it is, while also
being more complex than audiences might guess
at first.
After such a lengthy run, it's perhaps more
surprising that "King of the Hill" lasted
as long as it did and was only canceled in
Season 13.
According to Mike Judge, the series was essentially
canceled in 2005, only for Fox to surprise
the crew by ordering more episodes.
The episode originally intended to close out
the series was Season 11's "Lucky's Wedding
Suit," which sees Lucky and Luanne get married
alongside a subplot involving a frivolous
lawsuit.
However, the show was renewed yet again, making
the episode nothing more than the Season 11
finale.
By the time "King of the Hill" was actually
canceled, the show had already faced death
several times.
Though the abrupt end may have disappointed
viewers, Judge seemed fine with it, noting
to The Chicago Tribune —
"I think it's a good time to stop.
I'd rather stop when it's still decent, rather
than run it to the ground.
It'll be a little weird – this will be the
first time since 1992 that I haven't had a
show on the air.
But I'm OK with it."
Even some of the most popular sitcoms in TV
history have been criticized for having less
than satisfying conclusions, but the episode
"To Sirloin with Love" grants fans a fulfilling
final note by showing the sincere sense of
support and community that surrounds the Hills.
With Peggy spending much of the episode off
doing her own thing as Hank and Bobby go through
a whole emotional arc, this episode of "King
of the Hill" evades the standard feelings
of emptiness and lack of direction that many
finales suffer from.
"Usually your pep talks go in one ear and
out the other… but this time, I'm feeling
the pep!"
The charm of the "To Sirloin with Love" conclusion
is that it feels just like any other episode,
but it just so happens to knock it out of
the park by hitting on many of the show's
recurring themes.
Though the early parts of the episode feature
some of the best Hank and Bobby dialogue in
the whole series, the concluding moments take
it a bit easier by allowing the animation
to do the talking.
Scenes of the whole neighborhood coming out
of their homes one by one to enjoy a well-cooked
meal together tie together a show that, even
in its roughest moments, is about the transformative
power of loving your neighbors for who they
are.
The dynamic between a conservative father
and his free-spirited son makes up much of
the central focus of "King of the Hill," so
it might not be a huge surprise that the finale
takes their relationship as its central focus.
Over the course of the series, Hank and Bobby
have their bond challenged in many ways — but
even without outside instability pushing things
to a head, there's the simple problem that
the two just don't have much in common.
While the show often sees them making peace
with their differences, "To Sirloin with Love"
provides a heartwarming twist by finally giving
them a shared interest.
When Peggy announces that she'll be off with
friends for the night, Hank is concerned,
noting that he and Bobby don't have all that
much they can talk about without her around.
However, they connect at a restaurant when
Bobby correctly identifies a flaw in the steak
on his plate, showing Hank that he is a top-notch
purveyor of meats.
"Everybody knows the tiny bone side of the
sirloin is the most tender.
What kind of steak joint is this?!"
A man at a nearby table agrees, introducing
himself as the coach of the Heimlich County
Junior College meat examination team, which
he asks Bobby to join.
When Bobby asks for his dad's approval, Hank
is so overwhelmed with joy that he immediately
agrees.
Just like that, Bobby's on the team, and Hank
has never been happier.
Keeping in step with the core format of "King
of the Hill," Bobby soon experiences doubts
about the team his father is so overjoyed
to see him become a part of.
Though Bobby immediately proves himself a
skilled grader by noticing a detail in a cow
carcass that his teammates don't immediately
see, he clocks them as being a little weird
right off the bat.
When they go out the night before they're
meant to compete, they tell Bobby he can't
jinx them by eating meat before the event.
After that, they throw red pepper flakes in
the faces of their competitors, shocking Bobby.
However, his coach encourages this behavior,
making Bobby question his future with the
group.
"Did you know that no one can hear you scream
from inside a meat locker?”
When Bobby makes a simple mistake and the
others deride and ostracize him, he tells
Hank he has to quit the team.
This causes Hank to have somewhat of an overreaction,
as he was so excited to finally bond with
his son.
This isn't so much about the competition as
it is about their relationship — a point
that's driven home when Bobby sees the grill
his dad has bought for him in celebration.
Peggy tells him in no uncertain terms that
Hank's disappointment comes from the happiness
he felt when he realized that he could finally
share an important part of his life with Bobby.
Even though Hank's feelings of sadness around
Bobby's desire to quit the meat examination
team are justified, Bobby has every right
to leave the strange group.
The shady tactics they resort to in order
to claim a win are only the tip of the iceberg.
Interactions with the others show Bobby that
there's something deeply weird about every
one of the people on the team.
The focus on competition over enjoyment unsettles
him, and plays a major role in his decision
to step away.
It's clear that Bobby not only has a good
sense of ethics, but also a healthy ability
to keep his ego in check.
Hank's pride in Bobby is adorable, and his
stubbornness eventually wanes as he realizes
just how right Bobby was about the team.
Finally understanding his son's desire to
quit, Hank learns a classic "King of the Hill"
lesson — but "To Sirloin with Love" makes
it easier on him than usual.
He quickly realizes the error of his ways
and seeks to rectify his mistakes.
Although "To Sirloin with Love" is technically
not the final episode of "King of the Hill"
— more on that later — it's hard to imagine
a more fitting end to the series.
The story ends with Hank and Bobby sharing
a delightful moment as they feed the neighborhood
together.
Even though the two don't always see eye to
eye, their shared love of grilling can always
bring them back together.
"Oh, you're just getting started, Bobby.
You'll be grilling your whole life."
"Just like you."
"Yeeup."
Despite Hank's consistent, series-defining
declaration —
"That boy ain't right."
Bobby is arguably the most "right" person
in "King of the Hill," and he proves it in
the finale.
Not only does he show surprising maturity
in pleading his case with the waitstaff when
he realizes his steak isn't what it should
be, but he's also a great team member who's
capable of working with the goals of a larger
group in mind.
Bobby's calm and friendly demeanor doesn't
seem as special as it is until we see it contrasted
with people who have such a long way to go
in their own development.
If Bobby's arc had to come to a close, this
was the time and place for it to happen.
Though he was always capable of being profound
beyond his years, here he's able to forgive
and connect with his dad even when Hank is
being a bit immature.
Besides that, he puts aside his own feelings
of resentment toward the team that treated
him badly, stepping in where he's needed so
that they're able to succeed in the competition
— even though he no longer wants anything
to do with it.
Juggling his father's expectations, the need
for personal boundaries, and his own self-interest
successfully is the kind of thing that has
us taking notes on how to be more like Bobby
Hill.
A consistent truth in "King of the Hill" is
that you should keep things honest no matter
how much you want to win.
That message comes back in a big way in "To
Sirloin with Love."
Bobby notices the shady dynamics of the meat
examination team early on, and he finds himself
completely unwilling to engage in their over-the-top
attempts to hurt their competitors.
Though we know by now that Bobby is a good
kid who will follow his own ethics above any
group dynamics, his intuition has been honed
into something truly impressive by the series'
conclusion.
This episode is far from the only competition-gone-wrong
to appear on "King of the Hill," but it is
one of the most revealing for its characters.
The added stress on Bobby to do well with
the team so his father will continue to be
proud of him is extreme, but even despite
Hank's disappointment, there's no question
that he truly loves his son.
Earlier in the episode, when Bobby gets upset
with himself for only getting fourth place,
Hank is overjoyed, celebrating his fourth-place
slot with a level of enthusiasm that can't
help but be endearing.
The knowledge that Hank doesn't care whether
Bobby succeeds — only that they have a common
interest — only pushes forward the enduring
message of fair play that pops up so often
throughout the series.
Among Hank Hill's beer-drinking buddies, Boomhauer
is always the most mysterious one, with his
slurred, rapid-fire way of talking making
it nearly impossible to understand him.
"It dang ol' complicated, you know, man, it's
like a dang ol' Rubik's cube man, like, talking
about blue, red, man, then you get to one
side and you, like, messed up the other side,
man."
Initially being pretty one-dimensional, Boomhauer
is often defined by his interest in women
and muscle cars, though his luck with both
is regularly called into question when the
series starts unpacking the details of his
life.
Regardless, Boomhauer is highly astute and
capable of giving calm and reasonable advice
to others, making him a helpful guy to have
around.
By the end of the series, Boomhauer gets a
few spotlight episodes and even some fairly
profound moments with characters like Bobby
and Hank.
After spending the whole series without ever
actually stating what his job is, the last
episodes tell us that Hank's bestie Boomhauer
was really a Texas Ranger the whole time.
This revelation occurs in a casual scene in
which Boomhauer smells the grill outdoors
and leaves his home to join in.
His wallet pops open, revealing a badge and
solving one of the show's big mysteries in
a perfectly low-key way.
Does this mean that Boomhauer was casually
spying on anti-government conspiracy theorist
Dale throughout their friendship?
We may never know.
"To Sirloin with Love" acts as the finale
to "King of the Hill," but it wasn't the last
episode to actually air.
Four more episodes that had already been produced
premiered in syndication after the fact: "The
Honeymooners," "Bill Gathers Moss," "When
Joseph Met Lori, and Made Out with Her in
the Janitor's Closet," and "Just Another Manic
Kahn-Day."
These are more like ordinary episodes than
series finales, but that doesn't mean they
aren't still fun to watch.
Hank's mother announces her intention to marry
a man Hank hasn't even met, Bill decides to
combat his depression by getting some roommates,
and Joseph's love life picks up steam.
In "Just Another Manic Kahn-Day," the last
episode to air chronologically, the often
combative relationship between Hank and his
neighbor Kahn gains a new dimension as the
two spend some one-on-one time with each other.
With Minh and Connie on a trip, Hank is tasked
with checking in on his neighbor.
Deciding that medication is unnecessary, Hank
tells Kahn to not bother waiting in line at
the pharmacy.
"Yeah!
You're right!
I think I'll self-medicate with 50,000 BTUs
of ass-kicking hellfire!"
This sends Kahn into a manic episode in which
he becomes uncharacteristically upbeat and
wants to work endlessly on a shared grill
project with Hank.
However, Hank soon realizes he misunderstood
the extent of Kahn's bipolar disorder when
his neighbor hits a low point and is unable
to complete the project.
Though Hank doesn't always behave in the best
way, he and Kahn ultimately end up becoming
closer due to their newfound understanding.
To all good things, there must be an end.
Even though "King of the Hill" has an excellent
conclusion, it can still feel bittersweet
to fans who wanted another 13 seasons.
If that's you, you may be in luck, as there
have been recent rumors of a revival series
coming from original co-creators Mike Judge
and Greg Daniels.
Though very little information has been released
to date around what we could expect from a
return to Arlen, chances are it would involve
quite a lot of talk of propane and propane
accessories — and we wouldn't want it any
other way.
In January of 2022, Daniels told Collider
that his and Judge's idea for a revival would
start with a time jump, aging up the show's
characters significantly.
However, it's still unclear whether or not
the revival will actually happen.
In September of 2022, it was announced that
Fox was uninterested in bringing the series
back, leaving Judge and Daniels without a
definite home for their reboot.
"King of the Hill" could still be coming back,
however, and Judge and Daniels seem excited
to bring it to life.
Spending years with the Hills was a formative
experience for a lot of sitcom fans, so here's
hoping the new series will be every bit the
low-key slice-of-life we've come to know and
love.